I am thrilled and it is my pleasure to
introduce you to our guest speaker today
um Pedra mochran
pedram um in this webinar will describe
um why AI has become such a high
priority and how Business Leaders can
think about developing and adopting AI
solution
you will provide an overview of the key
AI terms Concepts trends that inform
business strategy
along with advising companies around the
world on entrepreneurship business model
disruption and Technology Innovation
strategy pedram teaches courses at
Stanford through the School of
Engineering
and he teaches the xddt 224 building and
an AI enabled organization Force which
is part of the Stanford digital
transformation program
before we begin for our audience please
remember you can enter in a question at
any time and we do encourage you to
submit your questions earlier during
this webinar
with that I'm going to hand the webinar
over to pedram pedram welcome and thank
you for being with us today
well thanks so much for having me
um it's a delight to talk about one of
my favorite topics and it's
strange even though I'm not a computer
scientist and I'm not classically
trained in AI itself for me the not only
teach a course on on the topic but to
even come and speak to you all about it
um so I just wanted to start by giving
you a bit of a background as to what is
my relationship with AI and how it all
came to be
back in the day long long long time ago
I used to be a chip designer in fact my
focus was on computer architecture
and it was fascinating to understand how
computers work
and it's really interesting also to then
start to think about how do you apply
that context to how the world works and
how the world operates and so in fact
how I got into Stanford for graduate
school in the first place was predicated
on my desire to apply at the time uh
where were called evolution-based
algorithms to risk management and to
asset price and so it was taking an
engineering approach to think about how
markets actually operated
now if you think about that context this
is going back a couple of decades now at
this point aging myself
the interesting thing was the world of
of AI as we know it today and machine
learning and all the different uh models
that are being used in practice weren't
as prevalent and so it was still viewed
with some skepticism around this notion
of this Dark Art and this dark science
or of of AI and machines that can kind
of think on their own to help with how
the world actually operates
many years later I actually stepped into
the world of venture capital and that's
really when uh the art of AI was getting
implemented deeply inside of a lot of
new uh and emerging technology companies
and one of the most fascinating ways to
understand how AI gets applied is to
view it through the lens of an
entrepreneur people that have an
understanding of what the technology can
do and are thinking about how to solve
problems specifically in the in the
greater good of the world to take these
Innovations in these Concepts productize
them and then take them to Market so a
lot of what I'm going to share with you
is not only what I've seen and what I've
dealt with from an entrepreneur's
perspective as an investor helping them
understand how to create these
businesses but also the other side of
things is as Anita pointed out I also
advise a number of large companies and
helping them understand how can they
start to then incorporate some of these
Technologies into their practice on a
daily basis so without further Ado I'm
going to dive in to our topic of
discussion today which
begins with a big overview of of this
notion of data and AI
and the first thing that I wanted to say
is the reason that I get excited about
putting this course together in the
first place is because I was seeing this
Divergence of conversations happening in
the world of AI there's a lot of people
that were technologists that were
talking about the Deep Technologies and
the emerging algorithms of AI and how
they can put that to practice into use
so think about this as being sort of an
AI ecosystem driven by technologists
speaking to technologists and sometimes
that's not very useful for people that
are trying to get an understanding of
what's going on on the other side
there's people that are talking at it at
such a high level that it's almost like
a very very big macro view but you
really don't know how these Technologies
get applied to that because you know
there's a huge gap in terms of that
understanding
and so the course itself is really
driven around giving you a perspective
that's not so entrenched and ingrained
in terms of the technology itself but
it's not just a a very big altruistic
view of what AI can do either it's
really about a practical understanding
of what it means and some technical
terminologies and some examples around
how to think about what is the
difference between supervised
non-supervised learning and how can that
be useful for you well as a manager or
somebody who's leading a project like
this it's always good to at least be
well versed in the big picture and then
leave the details to the people that are
experts but if there's a disconnect
between you not even understanding what
it even means to think about supervised
learning or how it even works well then
you're you're not going to have that
good level of empathy to actually be
able to drive this uh these projects
forward so
and then the last part of that is going
to be focused on the strategy right how
do we think about that which is core to
a lot of the things that I do or in and
around Innovation which is to just
Define and describe strategies for
things that may appear to be abstract or
hard to deal with
so I want to begin
with something that I do and actually in
a lot of my Innovation talks which is
talk about this thing called the
dunning-kruger effect and for those of
you that are familiar with it you'll
recognize the curb and for those of you
that aren't what I like to do is to
frame this in terms of a very simple two
by two and think about
understanding right of a human being or
an organization
if we don't really understand it at all
right that's that's what the uh the
x-axis representing right versus we have
some experience with the topic or we're
experts in the topic
how does that relate to our confidence
what you would anticipate is that
something like this is a linear curve
where it says well the more confident we
are about something then the greater
chance of us being an expert in it and
vice versa the more expertise we have
about a subject matter the more
confidence we should have
with the amazing thing about this
research was that it Unearthed a very
interesting pattern and it actually
looks like this
and they did this with a lot of graduate
students where at the beginning they had
so much confidence and so much
excitement but then they more they
learned about the topic and the more
that they internalized all that
knowledge
even though they're becoming better and
better at the topic and the subject
matter of becoming bigger experts in it
their confidence was actually dropping
and I actually overlay this in terms of
where I think the notion of AI and
Innovation and bringing new things
um falls into this danger zone of a lot
of organizations
at first it's
ecosystems and people and organizations
that know nothing about the subject
they're just very confident because
they've read an article you know or seen
something on TV Great take that
enthusiasm but now let's actually bolt
on uh practice and expertise in in
confidence
the other side of it is organizations
that have so much entrenched
capabilities but because they've seen
some of the dark side of what can go
wrong they actually end up handcuffing
themselves and they don't have the
courage and the confidence to actually
go and pursue these things because it
might not have worked in the past and so
they're bringing all of those Legacy
Thoughts with them as we go forward
this unfortunately is the exact same
thing with AI
because a lot of people don't really
understand what it is it's almost like a
dark science you can basically say we'll
throw AI at the problem and we'll solve
it that gets us into the first bucket
on the other side because this subject
matter has been around for decades and a
lot of times it hasn't actually yielded
promising results a lot of people then
also then assume that well you know here
we go again and it's not going to work
this time either and it throws us into
the middle bucket where the observations
of History are actually tainting what
our capabilities are going forward
and it's extremely important as managers
to understand where also you are and how
to deflect some of the criticism even
though you know that the world has
changed but at the same time how to
Tamper the enthusiasm when you know for
example that it's not just around thrown
up thrown around buzzwords it's actually
about Building Systems of work and so
hopefully this program gives you a sense
of of how to think about that
so why is this important today
well there's an aspirational goal that a
lot of people think about which is how
to become more digital and more
digitally enabled and how to shift
towards this notion of being a digital
operating company
now
we've seen this in terms of a lot of
tech companies take on this model where
you have almost like this non-linear
exponential value creation opportunity
that expands with the more data that you
have and the more users that you might
have especially in the world of consumer
internet
that a traditional operating model only
scales in terms of the efficiencies of
scale but not because of the fact that
you're actually generating some outsized
value because of the data that you're
collecting
and so as a result of this this is where
we want to start to then think about how
do we take advantage of that underlying
data to create this hopefully
aspirational exponential value creation
opportunity going forward
which brings us to this term Alpha
Alpha is used in public markets and in
financial markets to think about an
investment strategy that beats the
market right it's your Edge it's your
secret sauce if you will
It's associated with your ability to
create excess returns
and so the way that we want to start to
think about this is how can we gain
Alpha how can we become better than what
the market could typically do based on
some unfair advantages of Secret Sauce
that we might have
and in many instances this is data so as
we start to reflect back on that
exponential value creation opportunity
that effectively reflects that company's
Alpha its secret sauce
so if we go back in time and actually
look at Value Creation in general and
how companies have historically thought
about creating Alpha
we've migrated from organizations that
view outside returns being driven by
their assets right so for example think
about land use rights or the assets
associated with factories or stores or
real estate
these are physical properties equipment
inventory and the like right which
effectively gives you the ability to
then go and pursue Market opportunities
because you had those assets under
control
several decades ago we started to shift
that model and we started to say well
you can also get outside's returns by
thinking about intellectual property
right which is your unique expertise and
your knowledge of the world and how you
can actually drive your understanding
and your intellect within your
organization to then start to drive
these outsized returns and you can think
about things like patents and you can
think about things like Trade Secrets
where it comes to things for example
like manufacturing or chip design where
you have an unfair Advantage because of
knowledge
as we start to now shift into what a lot
of people refer to as the fourth
Industrial Revolution and thinking about
data this is where information
is now starting to become your IP of the
past if you will your unfair advantage
to generate Alpha
and this is a very very important
process in understanding from a business
perspective before we even start to talk
about AI
because one of the underpinning elements
of AI today especially is your access to
data is your ability to think about how
can we actually leverage the data that
we have either access to the data that
we're creating or the the data that we
can actually acquire and make use of for
whatever reason that might be to then
make that as part of our AI strategy our
unfair Advantage how can we use data to
drive Alpha
and that really is the underlying
premise of how we should be thinking
strategically around applying AI for
business decisions and for business
applications
now
you mentioned this you know fourth
Industrial Revolution we can then
overlay that in terms of what has
happened historically
well what's happened historically is if
you go back to one of the most
well-studied and oldest ecosystems in
the world namely England that's been
studied what we've seen here is that the
English economy grew linearly with
population over centuries
and then something interesting happened
and you can imagine what that is
there is an inflection point that
inflection point started to drive an
exponential economy
and this Maps up
neatly against what we commonly refer to
as the industrial revolutions the first
the second the third and now we are in
the dawn of the fourth
and this is exactly how we should be
thinking about this use of data so where
we went from manual labor manual work to
mechanized work right driven by steam
engines and then driven by electricity
um and then driven by
over time more Machinery you started to
create outsized returns and outside
capabilities that you couldn't have done
otherwise and then as a result of that
you made the previous generation of
doing things of manufacturing the
procurement of Service delivery obsolete
this is where we are today is to think
about how can we then take advantage of
the tool sets that we have available to
us today to continue this Evolution much
the same way that several decades ago we
couldn't even imagine what the internet
could be
right when I grew up email was just
taking off right people just I mean we
literally could have made up any email
address on any server because there
wasn't that many people using email
again I'm dating myself
but now you can start to then imagine
what would the world look like without
the internet how would you even do
Commerce for conduct any regular
business without this notion of the
Internet available to you
one day soon we're going to have the
same type of conversations around the
use of data and intelligence
and so the further we are ahead of that
curve the more strategically place will
be to take advantage of all the riches
that can come with it and again a lot of
this has to do with data
so where are we now
why are we talking about this digital
transformation
there's a Confluence of things that are
happening simultaneously that are
driving this conversation
and sometimes it's just one thing right
for example it's electricity right
but in other times it's actually a
series of things that need to come
together exactly at that right time
before the value starts to become
realized
and what we'll talk about this notion of
AI specifically this subject matter has
been around for a long time and in fact
in the course we'll talk about a little
brief history of it as well
it's been around for decades
but the other elements of this that are
really driving this transformative
change haven't been and this is what
makes this whole thing so interesting
so the underlying capabilities that we
have from computational perspectives and
infrastructure
cloud computing we haven't had this for
decades and decades we haven't had this
plethora of data that we have access to
for decades and decades
and now as we start to then think about
this broad access of iot devices the
internet of things and sensors and
sensor data and the ability for us to
actually generate data from the
environment from our physical ecosystem
becoming unbelievably cheap to the point
where it's almost practically free now
all of these are coming now together to
create this digital transformation
Revolution that we're witnessing today
and we're witnessing this not just in
the tech ecosystem we're now starting to
witness this across all different
domains and so for just a quick snapshot
of what that looks like there's a recent
study by McKinsey and company that was
around how do I even think about the
value of AI versus just traditional you
know analytics we might have had before
in the incremental value is literally in
the trillions of dollars and as you can
see here it's across virtually every
single ecosystem that you can imagine
so irrespective of where you're coming
from you should be thinking outside the
box in fact in many cases as I was told
recently you should be thinking without
the Box
imagine a world where you can then think
about the data and how you can connect
that data to Value independent of the
fact that you may not be coming from a
technology-based company but you have
access to this Alpha that you can then
leverage now whether it's banking or
insurance or Pharma or retail all of
these incredibly large ecosystems all
stand to gain from the impact of AI and
again taking advantage of all these
different things that are coming
together from cloud computing to data to
actually the new technologies and new
algorithms that are being created even
on a daily basis in and around AI
so
one thing that you may be thinking of is
I've been thrown around this concept of
artificial intelligence and AI for quite
some time
what does it mean
how do you define it
it's actually one of the core components
and one of the things that I found
um quite rewarding when I was actually
creating this course in the first place
is going to people that are truly
experts in it and asking them what they
think about Ai and how do they Define it
and you'd be surprised that the
definition is all isn't always as clear
as you would hope it would be
there are a few definitions that I will
throw at you and then we'll reserved you
know some of the insights in the in the
course itself
but generally speaking as a branch of
computer science right that deals with
um intelligent behavior in computers
so it's typically the way to think about
that is how does a computer system
perform tasks that are normally require
human intelligence to do such as for
example visual perception or speech
recognition or decision making
and how do we then actually create a
mechanism by which the computer can do
that instead of the human being
and it's funny it's one of those things
where the more we go back in history
the more we can start to then take
things that are
daily things that we don't even think
twice about
and then apply this definition of AI and
then think about well
hmm
would that have been AI back when it was
first introduced
and there's a couple of of images here
I'm sharing it with you from the the
1940s in fact where
this was just common practice on a daily
basis right you had switchboard
operators you had elevator operators you
had people that were doing these manual
tasks that required some level of
intelligence to do
and then
they were replaced with automation
think about somebody that picked up a
phone that was used to speaking with
somebody and saying I need to speak with
Mr Mrs so and so and then they get
dispatched to it or I need to speak with
a certain department they get dispatch
to that because somebody was
interpreting that
and now think about that then being
replaced effectively with automation
It's Magic right for somebody that can
then just basically say magically I got
connected to the right person by this
notion of automation
and so at the time of adoption it's very
difficult to discern the difference
but over time we just take it for
granted
now the other way of thinking about sort
of this this element of automation as we
start to think about this incorporation
of AI is also to then understand more
broadly speaking the spectrum of AI
from narrow to Super
and this is where I think a lot of
confusion sets in
so what happens in a lot of instances
where I speak with Business Leaders that
are not necessarily technologists
um and they think about AI
they
project onto the conversation things
that they've seen in movies right these
robots that do these magical things and
you can ask them anything about anything
and then they can basically make
decisions and unearth the information
for you and you know stuff happens
but the reality is we all want to we
actually live in a world of of narrow AI
today right and if we think about
something as as basic as a Roomba which
I'm sure many of you uh own and
sometimes you own two of them because
you know they get a little bit smarter
over time
um this is also AI right this is also
how we start to then think about AI
powered devices and tools
now
is this The Cutting Edge or the bleeding
edge in many cases it is right in many
cases the bleeding edge of AI enables us
to do very simple tasks but to do them
in a repeatable potentially safe way
that we couldn't have done otherwise
where we start to incorporate different
elements of sensing different elements
of actuation different elements of
potentially decision making
that a very simple device needs to take
into account before it can conduct
something as basic as wiping popcorn off
the floor
so we really need to contextualize what
do we mean when we start to think about
AI are we talking about this very broad
definition that we might see in movies
that that's a little bit outside of of
the realm of reality
or are we starting to think about how
can we take the things that are ready
today and start to then put them to use
and we are really much more closer to
this narrow AI world today before we
start to then think about generalizing
and so unless you're a technology
company such as like a Google or a
Facebook that basically has entire
server Farms
um devoted to this topic and has more
data than you can even imagine
it doesn't really make much sense for us
to start to think about General AI
applications towards traditional
business opportunities
and so I don't want to dampen
expectations of what is possible today
but unless we can start to then confine
and bound our definitions we're not
going to be able to get out of our own
way we're going to be stuck in that
first part of the Dunning Kruger effect
curve that I showed you about where it's
all about enthusiasm and nothing about
execution
now
why am I describing all of this why why
are we even talking about AI when we
start talking about the power of data to
get to begin with
well
one of the key things for us to
understand is
in order for us to go through this true
digital transformation
it means we have to have a greater
Reliance on data
I'm gonna it's gonna be almost like a
broken record so I apologize in advance
if I speak about data a little bit too
much but it's true it's it's the engine
it's the fuel that makes everything work
now
the problem that we've had with data is
if you rely on it too much you could
draw the wrong conclusions right because
you may be looking at it just from a
pure statistical perspective without any
broader understanding of the context of
it
but if we then eliminate the use of data
at all and then just basically do the
gut field management style that may have
worked historically
well we're not necessarily then taking
advantage of these unforeseen
relationships that may actually have a
lot of information a lot of insights
that we can actually take advantage of
and so it's the blending and the
balancing of being able to understand
how to use data and how to still
maintain our understanding of a
hypothesis-driven approach to making
decisions into creating outcomes that
becomes powerful
and so
this is the approach that we want to
start to take as we start to then think
about how do we build an AI system how
do we start to incorporate part of that
hypothesis oriented approach that we're
very comfortable with
while at the same time we start to then
take advantage of data
and here is a very simple framework and
again I want to apologize it might seem
too simple and it might appear a little
bit weird in wonky but it's actually
helped me a lot when I thought about
this notion of applying Ai and as I try
to coach and Mentor both entrepreneurs
students Technologies technologists
Business Leaders alike on how to think
about it
and I typically try to think about it is
a three-legged stool
so to me this is becomes a very simple
framework to think about the basic
building blocks of an AI system and
we'll get into all kinds of details
inside the course itself around all of
these things but I just want to shed
light on a couple of these key issues
so there are three likes to this stool
as you can see right
the one is data the second are the
algorithms so so where are we in terms
of our ability to manipulate the data as
well right and how sophisticated are the
algorithms that we have access to
and then the third is the platforms
which is our ability to actually compute
and to take advantage of the algorithms
on top of the data but in an efficient
timely and
you know economically feasible way
these support the problem definition
and much like a three-legged stool which
the legs by themselves right don't
really add the value it's the seat that
you sit on that is really the core
that's the same thing that I want you to
take away from this conversation
this building block
has to begin with what are you trying to
do first
defining the problem defining the
purpose of why you're even pulling these
things together
so it's like a stool without a seat
it's just three legs they don't really
do anything for you
the seat is what brings us all together
and actually creates the value
proposition right the legs you need to
make sure that the thing just doesn't
topple over right so you don't have a
one-legged stool
but I really want you to think
about the problem definition is your
starting point
and much like entrepreneurship or
innovation right the first building
block should be about what problem are
you trying to solve what is the key
Market motivation what is the customer
motivation whether your customer is
internal to your organization or
external to your organization as in
somebody that you actually are serving
what is their motivation what are they
seeking what problem are they looking to
solve what are the domains of things
that we can think about that we could
enhance for them
now again that your customer could be an
internal organization
or it could be truly somebody that
you're serving as part of your
organization outside of the company
but it's really important to start them
and think about what problem is it that
we're really trying to solve for here
from there we then shift through the
legs we start to then think about data
right and what kind of data do we have
access to how do we start to think about
the kind of data that we have and how
how does that become useful to us how do
we start to think about this difference
between structured and unstructured data
where structured data is something that
is already very well organized it's in
tabular formats we may be collecting it
via our existing systems already and
then unstructured data is all of the
stuff that's just kind of flowing to us
that's not tabular right it's not
necessarily organized in a way that is
really accessible or machine readable or
analyzable via a spreadsheet or
traditional type of algorithm and how do
we start to think about this entire
universe of data that can then fuel our
ability to think about generating these
these outputs and these outcomes
and that's really really
um the important thing from there
obviously takes a little bit of
sophistication and talent to understand
how do we start to then think about the
engineering oriented side of things and
the platforms that we that we want to
use those are decisions that should be
made by the the technical experts and
then obviously what is The Cutting Edge
of the algorithms that we can actually
then take advantage of and put into
practice
and a lot of these algorithms
are really predicated on two things one
is on the modern world of data and the
large volumes of data that we have
accessible to us
and the second is this notion of machine
intelligence
and so for the final few minutes I just
want to touch on a couple of things
around machine intelligence
specifically machine learning
a lot of people
confusing conflate Ai and machine
learning
and so just very very simply machine
learning is a subfield of artificial
intelligence
it enables computers to learn on their
own
and the Machine learning algorithms
allow us to identify patterns and
observe data to build the models and
then to explain the world and to predict
things without having to a priori
explicitly program those rules into
place
the typical example of how to think
about this is to observe a child
it's based on the same Concepts where
through trial and error and through
observation and through outcome
a child does not necessarily know how to
manipulate their fingers
they do that by observing over time
these actions until they can refine it
and hone that skill in a much more
complex way as they continue to learn
into into a
incorporate this as part of their psyche
as part of their decision making as part
of their general intelligence
and so it's this response to experiences
it's a similar type of thing that we
want to then think about
um conveying in terms of traditional
programming to machine learning based
programming
so traditional programming a computer is
instructed in a very specific way to
carry out a set of tasks right so you
understand what it does you program it
it's almost like the child it's born
with an understanding of how to
manipulate the thumb of the forefinger
and to do things at a high precision
and guess what it doesn't continue to
learn from that because it basically is
stuck with whatever you taught it so it
doesn't actually get better over time so
if you think about a child it first
learns to pick up one thing and then the
more sophisticated it becomes as it
learns how to manipulate this particular
skill set and learns how to manipulate
it with such fine Precision that it can
start to use a chopstick or to write
and think about that as being the
ultimate in terms of precision work that
you might be able to do versus a
one-year-old you'd be excited if they
can just pick up you know the pen in the
first place let alone to even begin to
write with it
and so traditional programming limits us
by having the human intelligence
programmed directly what the system can
do with machine learning we set it up
such that as it observes it can actually
refine and hone and continue to evolve
those skills and become better and
better at that over time now this
doesn't apply to absolutely everything
and the limitations and how it works
we'll describe in the course because
it's actually ever so slightly
complicated but that's the way to think
about the difference right is this
ability for us to continue to learn and
for the machine to continue to learn
that very specific skill based on
observed data and on observed outcomes
that we can then say this is what a
machine learning mindset and approach is
in terms of how we want to program
something in an output versus a
traditional programming model
so hopefully that gives you a quick
sense of how to think about that
and again if you take nothing away what
I'd like you to do especially from a
business perspective is to apply this
model
throwing AI at something without a
clearly defined problem doesn't make
sense right so the clearly defined
problem in the case that I just
described to you is manipulating two
actuation arms to actually pick up a pen
and do something with it right so for
example that becomes a problem
definition
then we would think about the data we
would think about the types of
algorithms that we would use and then we
think about the computational platforms
and the AI infrastructure that we would
need for this to actually be able to
operate
without the problem definition throwing
AI at something doesn't make sense so
it's very very important to begin with
that then to ask the question of what
data do we have what algorithms should
we be thinking about this basically is
depending on the experts and do we have
the right Platforms in place for us to
even be able to implement these things
to extract the value that we're looking
for
so
a simple way of putting this into
practice right which is going to be my
final thought for you
is to apply the six simple questions in
and around this framework always begin
with why why do we believe that there is
a business opportunity or a problem
worthy of being solved
this is our problem definition begin
with that why from there we want to
start to then think about again thinking
about this notion of data being the fuel
so without the data the algorithms don't
really have anything to act on so what
is the underlying data or the fuel that
is going to be helping to drive this
solution and derive this outcome that we
have and sometimes you might say we have
this data what questions can we ask of
it it's fine
from there we want to start to think
about who has the expertise designed to
develop the algorithms to validate the
models
do we have the infrastructure to then be
able to to do this in today's Cloud
environment that's absolutely prevalent
almost everywhere but you've all you
also want to validate that that you
within your organization have access to
the capabilities that the cloud offers
for you in these applications it becomes
part of your decision Matrix
from there we also want to address the
how can we measure the benefits right
it ties out again to this problem
definition so once we go through the
cycle we want to revisit the problem
definition and make sure that we have
the very clearly defined benefits that
we can measure so we can then Benchmark
the capabilities of AI right and so then
we can Benchmark how we even proposition
for it to come to Market
and then we want to then after address
the question of timing
which is when when should the
organization make this dedicated
commitment to support the adoption of
this AI initiative if you have all of
these questions even roughly addressed
then the answer is now right and if you
don't that's absolutely fine let's start
to think about how do we put the
building blocks in place how do we
create the data strategy how do we think
about a long-term AI strategy such that
we can then incorporate this is the time
for us to act and then we act with
sufficient Resources with sufficient
talent and with sufficient oversight in
terms of how we're going to actually
roll these systems up and extract the
value from them
so hopefully this has just been a very
small introduction that some of the
topics we're going to talk about in the
course and we're going to get into a lot
of further detail almost painful levels
of detail around not only the building
blocks but also the incorporation of
best practices when we start to think
about incorporating and implementing a
data strategy and an AI strategy within
the organization it's unfortunately far
too much detail to describe in in one
short webinar
um but hopefully the course will provide
some additional insights into how that
happens bedroom thank you for this
informative and um important
presentation about AI strategy and
digital transformation
um uh as I was saying that nobody heard
um before we transitioned to the Q a
everybody if you've got a question
please submit that question we've had
several come in over the presentation
but love to see some more
um I want to point out pedram during
your presentation you did mention how in
your course on the ddt224 course you did
these exclusive intimate interviews with
industry experts from all different
Industries about Ai implementations and
their perspective
um and uh I thought that that was some
of my favorite parts of the course
because you know you get to you know
when you take the course you get to see
the inside of these companies that you
normally would never see and you get to
see where they had successes and
failures so I just want to point that
out to everybody in the audience and
that the course does go deeper and
richer into the content all right pedram
we have gathered several questions many
questions coming in now so thank you
very much
um and I've got
um a couple for you so let's go ahead
and get started let's let's just start
with
um
uh
we've had a couple questions come in
about
feasibility of projects
um how would you do you apply the
building blocks the framework that you
talked about to assess the feasibility
of a project somebody asked about the
financial component of it
um can you talk a little bit about that
yeah absolutely
um
it's it's funny it's it's one of those
situations where
if you think about
um
project feasibility it's oftentimes
overwhelming to just say okay well
here's the thing that we want to do big
picture right and we're going to throw
AI at it and I it might sound like I'm
I'm I'm being extreme but I can't tell
you almost like a weekly basis I hear a
conversation like that right or somebody
says something like that to me right
where they say oh we're just gonna throw
AI at that thing and I'm like wait hold
on I don't even understand what that
means
I think whether it's the framework that
we talked about with the stool or if
it's some other framework that you use
I highly recommend thinking about a
structured approach to
being able to break down something that
is as amorphous and as sometimes
ill-defined as AI
um and then apply it to something else
that might also have uncertain outcomes
without a framework so even if you just
think about those four different
building blocks I think the first thing
is do we have a clear understanding of
the problem that we're trying to solve
and and sometimes it's it's really
really important to look at that and say
okay do we really need AI to solve that
problem right and then how can we
actually think about this thing
um that is so complex that we can't even
Define what the problem is if you can't
Define what the problem is right
what are you going to throw AI at what
are you going to throw your algorithms
at and so that's the first
important part of it from there then the
next question becomes well do you have
the fuel do you have the data do you
have access to the data do you have
permission to use the data how rich is
it and how useful and practical is it
for you to be able to take advantage of
that
you may not be able to address the
algorithms part
um which is fine right but but it's
always an interesting question and then
think about you know is this can we
actually think about you know the
existing state of the art even being
able to address this thing or are we
again applying science fiction to being
able to break this problem down
and then the last piece of that has to
do with this element of this platform
approach
um and what I mean by that is when you
think about a platform you want to think
about
do you have access to the ability to
actually run not only the computational
resources that are required and the
networking resources that are required
for these uh for these systems to
actually operate but also all the data
management data storage and all the
other like and if it requires for you to
have permission to use things that are
on the cloud because you don't have
access to those let's make sure you do
that
but I also want to make sure that we
highlight and I'm sure there's a second
question on this and I'm jumping the gun
here
um I also want to highlight this
distinction between this this platform
versus the algorithms and they're very
very different
and and I want you to think about a very
simple example right
um to hopefully paint this picture in
your mind
so
um I've Got Friends that work in the uh
at Amazon in the electric group so I
understand the the big picture stuff
that they're doing right and so without
disclosing any of their the details I
want you to think about it from a
consumer perspective
you you walk into a room and then you
say hey blank I don't want to turn on
all your Alexa devices so hey blank
um turn off my lights or turn on my
lights because I can't see anything and
my hands are full
and that's assumed that you've got the
algorithms that can do that perfectly
with 100 accuracy precision and they do
it they nail it they know you they know
your accent they know exactly what
you're saying
but the infrastructure takes 12 minutes
for the answer to respond in 12 minutes
for your lights to come on
so this is why I'm saying it's not just
about the algorithms the algorithms
could be perfect
but you have to think about in the
context of the utility of what it is
that you're providing
and this is where understanding the
platform piece of it is equally
important right so what level of
performance does this thing need to be
before the value is realized I can't sit
there with sort of two watermelons
underneath my hands waiting for Alexa to
turn on my lights
um when I'm walking into a dark kitchen
for example right I need it to be
roughly instantaneous
and so this is the big picture of what
we want to start to think about and each
element each very simple element of that
framework that I shared with you
hopefully at least gives you a mental
rubric to think about when it comes to
feasibility
great thank you
um we have a another question actually
it's a number of people have asked
similar questions
um or someone who wants to become an AI
professional
um what would you recommend for them and
is it mandatory for an AI professional
to be a programmer a traditional
engineer to lead an AI focused
transformation within their company or
organization
and um
you know the the the follow-on question
was this do you have to be a
technologist you have to be an engineer
can you be a business business executive
and I'm going to add one more question
to that
how do you convince management that this
is the right thing to do
cool
well I guess I'm gonna have to cancel
all my meetings for the morning because
this is going to take four hours to
explain
um It's a Wonderful question and I don't
think it's one of those questions where
there's a satisfactory simple answer
um and so I'll try to
be as open and honest with you as as I
can in terms of just just giving advice
to people
um first and foremost I think that
there's different skill sets required
for thinking about
um being somebody professionally
involved with AI there are people that
are experts when it comes to
understanding the
um Technologies from an algorithmic
perspective right so how do the
algorithms actually come together what
what is The Cutting Edge and how do we
apply those such that we can then sort
of fuse some of these technical
components together to deliver results
right it's very resource scientific
approach if you will there's also the
other side of that as I just mentioned
literally on the feasibility example
which is that there's an engineering
approach to this so you don't need to be
an expert in the algorithms right but
but there is a huge amount of work
that's required from an engineering
perspective to bring these systems to
life in a stable repeatable consistent
way and so there's an entire notion of
how to think about building the
infrastructure for these systems to
actually come to life and to be used in
a practical setting so I think that
there's a spectrum of things that that
one could do from a technical
perspective
but at the same time I don't think that
that's sufficient because it's not just
about the technology it's also about the
application
and so being versed enough to understand
the capabilities of the state of the art
having the empathy to speak with the um
the Technologies to understand what are
the current capabilities and what are
the current limitations we'll talk about
some of those in the course obviously
but but they're going to be case
dependent they're going to be domain
dependent so so speaking with some
people that are experts in the field in
terms of just being able to Define what
those boundaries are and being able to
understand what can be done with those
you do not need to be an expert in
computer science or AI to be able to
drive some of those decisions and and
some of those
um business oriented outcomes so I
actually think that the role is
multifaceted
and it's going to be multi-disciplinary
team in this whole AI ecosystem to to
actually create useful outcomes so I
personally think that it's all about
understanding where your skill sets are
today and how best you can leverage them
in this context are you very good at
framing questions are you very good at
helping to find consumer problems and
customer problems and being able to
translate that back into systems are you
good at just the algorithms and this is
sort of where you want to go and maybe
go back to grad school get a master's or
continue to refresh on what you're
already doing absolutely fine or are you
good on the engineering side of it but
you want to become better versed in
terms of how does that engineering angle
Orient yourself towards this and I also
want to then say that this is a huge
spectrum because there's a lot to do
with data engineering and understanding
how to even manage and manipulate data
that is also part of this broader
ecosystem right this broader digital
ecosystem so I think there's a lot of
different touch points there
so
do you need to be a technologist
absolutely not absolutely not I think
you just need to be open-minded you need
to be empathetic in terms of
understanding who else you need to speak
with you need to have the approach of
being willing to work in
multi-dimensional multi-faceted and
really multi-disciplinary teams
and you need to have the appetite to
stay relevant and current because this
field is changing almost on a daily
basis and that's that piece of the dun
and Kruger curve that I was mentioning
the first instances of AI has have been
around for 70 plus years
and
for for people that have been in this
space they'll tell you right that we've
had these winters of AI over time where
the interest of on the field has sort of
completely
um dissipated away and no one's
interested in it anymore because there's
a lot of hoopla a lot of hype and then
all of a sudden nothing happened and so
everybody just basically
um shunned it and said well look that's
that's not useful stuff and all of a
sudden then there's another emergence of
that and so on and so forth
I think what makes things different
today is understanding that there's
multi multiple different things that are
coming together and this is the number
one way of convincing management
is to say that historically we haven't
had this Confluence of Trends
simultaneously coming together
and so as a result it's not necessarily
that it's all new math or new algorithms
right A lot of these Concepts have been
around literally for decades
but it's around the fact that now we
have data that was unimaginable right we
have access to technical talent coming
out of undergraduate programs that's
unimaginable in terms of their insights
and expertise we have access to
infrastructure that would have cost us
hundreds of millions of dollars that we
can then basically have a credit card
swipe we have access to
and so all of these things are coming
together for us to experiment and
experiment relatively cheaply
and so unless there is a core desire to
continue to live in the past
I think management should be convinced
by by very simple jetting of the light
of these underpinning
um
currents that are all coming together to
support a new ecosystem and a new
Evolution of technology that can get
applied
and to not to oversell it
to get people enthused about it to get
them to understand that there's a
difference today versus literally 10
years ago that's how quickly Everything
Has Changed
but then not to to promise these
crazy conceptual Notions
um of what it can do and then set
yourself up for you know impending
failure
so that's that to me is is the best way
of doing that get people excited get
them aware about what's happening why
now is an interesting time to do that
and then a few small experiments that
are cheap to conduct and are worthy
outcomes to Showcase what can be done
so that to me is a is a logical approach
unless the CEO of your organization's
already said hey here's the next two
billion dollars we're going to devote to
this and say guns I'll go for it but
otherwise I think a very measured
approach to getting people bought into
very low-cost High Fidelity experiments
that you can run
um that are relevant to your
organization I think are fantastic
starting points
excellent thank you
um great advice
uh let's see here I have there's a
common theme that's coming from a number
of questions and it's it's weighty and
we only have a few minutes so
um but there's there are questions
coming in talking about emerging
economies
and the role that AI will play those
economies and how it will affect those
people in those those areas and those uh
companies and organizations and
countries
can you talk a little bit about that I
know the questions are coming different
perspective perspectives but I mean
that's the common theme
yeah there's so many different
perspectives uh around a a wonderful
question and a wonderful topic area that
I agree a few minutes doesn't do it
justice
um Let me let me shed light on it from
two different perspectives the first is
the is the workforce perspective where
you say well look if if
um if we just take a high level view of
emerging economies you can say well that
they're predominantly
um in let's say labor-centric markets
right not necessarily
information-centric ones and so what are
the impact if we have less Reliance on
labor and and I've heard it said by by a
lot of experts here as well right so I
can't take credit for this but the world
has so many problems and so many
opportunities to make it a better place
that talented people
um are aspirationally interesting people
will always find work and there's always
going to be an opportunity for us to
continue to apply Technologies to do
things better it's almost like saying
well look we're so used to doing things
by by oxen and cattle that you know
we're worried that if we buy these
tractors they're going to make us
obsolete well that's crazy if you don't
buy the tractors you're going to be
obsolete right and so you can see this
sort of this adoption of Technology have
happened over time
so
and and we'll talk about an example in
banking in the course uh itself but but
the notion of of job loss because of
um
because of automation because of AI is a
real one and we do need to transition
the workforce to being able to do
something different than what they were
doing today
but it's also unlocks an opportunity
do things that are much higher value as
well even in very specific ecosystems
like for example in farming right if we
can actually create better food using AI
right better better crops higher yields
you can start to then think about a much
broader ecosystem Even in our own
agriculture that you can then start to
think about so I think the fear of job
loss is something that a lot of people
haven't been able to completely wrap
their head around and I think if we look
at it historically yes it's true very
specific jobs will be lost
those same jobs will have to change and
morph but education actually unlocks a
whole new set of opportunities to build
on top of new professions that we can
create using technology one very quick
thing I I will say on the other
perspective is to also look at
ecosystems that don't have a lot of
legacy and so if we actually take a look
at Africa and what's going on in terms
of the banking ecosystem there or even
the digital ecosystem and how quickly
you actually end up leapfrogging
Technologies and advancing the entire
population because there's not a legacy
infrastructure that that you need to
then pay for it's actually a pretty
remarkable way of freeing yourself up if
you've invested billions and billions if
not trillions of dollars into
infrastructure that is slowly becoming
obsolete and you can then basically say
well we don't need any of that stuff
because now we can leave profit because
the technology and just adopt the new
one which is way cheaper and also
provides all the things that the
previous generation did that actually
creates a very amazing ecosystem and it
Proving Ground for new technologies that
you don't need to then go convince the
existing Legacy
um entrenched mindset that you need to
go about it that way so I actually think
that Emerging Markets are an amazing
opportunity for for Advanced
Technologies that are either data
Centric analytic-centric or AI Centric
awesome thank thanks for uh taking the
time to answer that question I know
we're running a little bit late but I do
want to thank you
um for your time today and the
presentation and you know taking the
time to answer that last question is
very important and it's it's in the
Stanford philosophy of making a
difference in the world I want to thank
everybody who stayed on it all the way
to the end there actually is still a
very large number of people that stay
with us through the entire webinar so
thank you all for joining us today and
with that um I want to wish you all a
great rest of your day wherever you are
in this world